j'espère simplement qu'ils vont aller
très vite parce que on attend avec
impatience d'avoir un peu plus de débit
on a un débit très médiocre depuis des
années et on aurait bien voulu avoir
qu'un seul et même opérateur et avoir la
fibre quoi rapidement très mauvais débit
très très très mauvais et surtout très
intermittent avec des une qualité très
variable un service qui est d'assez
mauvaise qualité voilà le mauvais débit
à voisin un problème récurrent qui
devrait bientôt changer d'ici mars 2017
les premiers habitants pour pouront
bénéficier de la fibre nous avons
installé concrètement les armoires de
mutualisation qui est un petit peu le le
le socle de du déploiement du FTTH sur
voisin le Bretonneux donc de la fibre
optique alors le premier lot qui est
fait sur 2016 et qui s'étalera un peu
sur 2017 correspond à peu près à 2000
logements sur voisin le trè haut débit
permettra au visinois de recevoir des
données numériques plus rapidement
l'arrivée de la fibre a été annoncée par
la commune en janvier de cette année
lorsqu'on a on a a appris que peut-être
il y avait une possibilité pour
l'arcepep de lever le de lever le le
monopole de SFR et Numéricable nous nous
sommes engouffrés dans la brèche pour
écrire et demander effectivement à ce
que Orange puisse postuler aussi à à
voisin c'est Orange c'est le budget
d'ore voilà après ils vont donner des
explications effectivement ce soir sur
comment après les les particuliers
peuvent se raccorder et choisir
l'opérateur qu'il souhaite
évidemment mais ça ne représente aucun
budget pour la commune une fois toutes
les installations réalisées plus de 4000
foyers seront connectés la totalité de
la commune devrait être entièrement
fibrée d'ici